something i'd like to address uh tonight
as you know a lot of
talk show hosts they come out and they
tell some monologue jokes
at the top of the show okay that's fine
but i like to innovate sorry
other hosts that's just me okay
check it out i have found a great new
way
to tell fantastic topical jokes that
adds excitement
and sex appeal watch this
hey did you hear this twitter deleted a
tweet
from president trump containing false
information
yeah trump said there's plenty more
where that came from
fighting for
[Music]
wait what was that andy trust me
this is gonna be huge okay okay
hey yesterday amazon ceo jeff bezos made
13 billion dollars in one day one day
yeah turns out a whole foods customer
bought one jar of almond butter
watch the institutions crumble
billionaires will bite the dust
pieces fortune is no match for coder
satire
conan i got to be honest these jokes are
kind of soft it doesn't matter about the
jokes
okay it's how i present it with sex
appeal
and 80s confidence in a speech yesterday
joe biden said that president trump is
quote
poisoning our democracy biden also said
his nurse
is stealing his credit cards
did you see what conan did there what a
clever thing to do
thought he'd take but he just said a
real
[Music]
what's a twister roo andy i don't have
time right now i'm busy selling these
jokes in a new and innovative way
this week is the kentucky derby known as
the fastest two minutes in sports
my wife said i'm more familiar with
these slowest two minutes
i think you know what conan saying do i
have to spell it out
when it comes to making love is like a
cold trout
yeah i think we've heard enough from
that guy singing a lukewarm hit from the
[Music]
80s
better get my ass to night school and
learn a new song
all right we have a uh great show
tonight jb smoove
gonna be joining us we'll be right back
andy uh warm up the crowd
keep them happy all right